the countdown is on to the Connors the
show premieres in just 13 more days on
ABC and you know what everybody is
wondering how they're going to move on
without Roseanne well we have a few new
clues from the just release first scenes
for Halloween Thanksgiving and Christmas
I say we follow the Connor tradition
spend every dime we have on Halloween
then we have nothing to be thankful for
or by guess with clue number one Laurie
Metcalf will take on more of a leading
role her character on Jackie appears in
12 of the 16 promo scenes there's no
place for the corn holders she may even
move into the family home here she is
carrying laundry through the house in
the background during poker night clue
number two Roseann will be killed off
while ABC has not confirmed her fate
this quick scene could be from her
funeral and in people's new cover story
Metcalf says quote Sarah and I had this
scene in the first show where we
addressed the grief and it was real and
still makes me choke off clue number
three
Roseanne's departure will be handled
with respectful humor all three cast
members say they owe it to the fans they
are also grateful Roseanne gave up her
financial stake in the show so it could
go on Roseanne recently told ety I did
walk away so people can keep their jobs
and you know there's always a silver
lining in every cloud and it's the tough
part is to find it walking away from it
was the right thing to do and by the way
John Goodman he's busy besides the
Conners he will also have a leading role
in an upcoming HBO comedy about a
televangelist family cannot wait to see
that
[Music]
[Applause]